hi everybody i'm jonathan trance and
today I have another tactical challenge
so when you see it on your screen go
ahead pause your video and let's see if
you can solve this week's puzzle this is
a position that arose from Alexander my
senko versus Liu Sheng Li from the world
rapid championship in Dubai 2014 so go
ahead at this point pause your videos
and see if you can find the amazing
tactic that my Cinco was able to find in
this position the winning move here
quite dramatic the move Knight takes g6
white is way ahead and development and
the black King is a little iffy so white
takes the opportunity to open them up
black took the night and again go ahead
see make sure you got this move right
now comes Queen takes h5 a very dramatic
sacrifice and it cannot be taken yeah
for example if you take it White has
Bishop f7 check and after King g4
there's several ways to mate so let's
just look at one after f3 King g3 King
f1 you're hopeless
any move you play rook h3 checkmate so
you can't take the Queen in the game he
decided to go back and well this
position is just really bad for black
and in a couple moves here he had to
resign thanks everybody for watching let
me know in the comments below were you
able to get it give this video a big
huge thumbs up if you got this one right
and I'll see you guys next week for
another tactical challenge